what cam this video playing Grand Master
mundra go roses gal she blonde german GM
who no listen thailand a friend of mine
season long time king's indian player
really knows what he's doing in the
opening let's see what is doing against
the Sarabande variation I think he plays
with an early 97 if i'm not mistaken
night beat his own no i wasn't i wasn't
really sure it's been a while that we
played the king's indian
so this is the the flag of Thailand 5
island how do you pronounce it actually
in English and German it's Thailand it's
time thailand probably not what is he
doing there's many possible setup see
585 96 and so on the Kings in unison of
course a rather flexible opening with
many possible setups
yeah one possible way to play that's
them see if I can transpose to a kind of
damage type of position this looks quite
nice I wonder g-form yeah well come on
let's go g-form maybe I okay h5 I can't
play h 3 h 5 is sometimes in a good
answer the Sun somehow looks like a
position that could easily arise also
from the other buck but in the our buck
you have the bishop on only two and yeah
I'll play age 3m yes and then aged for
going for a blockade
okay I can you can give the check on h4
I want to I want to play for long
castles of course now you can maybe even
give the check Bishop f2 and then Queen
f6 attacking f3 and quite interesting
the only thing that really amazes me is
that is spending so much time here I
mean come on it's a five-minute game not
wow what hmm I hope they start one of
his chest pupils are playing this looks
like this looks really crazy in my book
but maybe it's maybe it's playable night
g3 and queen age too
yeah well you can play eve now I can
play it Bishop g5 can can do that Queen
h2 that's f6 and as weird as it looks at
some it's playable
and yeah I think just be sure to you
five it is a playable move green edge to
f6
well what the heck is he doing on the
only 15 okay how much now queen age 2 is
blundering the Queen to Knight f3 okay
come on let's just protect this and then
try to get the the edge fall but this is
the system this is in fact playable that
it looks very strange but it's it seems
play long night h 5 ER so this may be a
possible IDM
hmm we all of course work g1 Rock g1 and
night f5 this is this is the way to go
yes okay he's trying to evacuate with
king of aid
how to play when you look at one and f4
I need to really open up the position
he's not really in a position at the
moment tomb to occupy me five so this
the scenes right takes Bishop takes no I
no no no rook takes us even more
interesting with the idea to play Bishop
deform or taking we should be formed if
it takes yeah well he SPS Bishop b5 but
this is not really a big threat even
Bishop d-4s a month now
hmm
how do i feel that there should be
something some technical way to make
progress okay I can retreat g5 is also
hanging and what's now but take here no
yeah I should have taken with the bishop
all along its would have been much
better
I'm trying for night if five but
yeah well he really did a good defensive
job of this night night eh 595 they're
simply not working as now he's got the H
farm and mold plate then he's very good
at this kind of stone I expected just
details actually but this is of course
very strong he's um he can invade with
the king ok let's see any way to relieve
some pressure maybe maybe this one
g5 is know if this is okay DRA offered
bra offered gras offered gras long are
on guys a friend of mine I'm not not
playing this nonsense on here especially
after he completely outplayed me but I
where the heck did I did I spoil this it
was such a great position
yeah the computer is typically merciless
and wants to take strategically terrible
but concretely winning check and now
this is the point which I didn't see and
this is combined this is threatening
Brooke age six and drew come roof g5
this is the point if it takes check this
is a mate so this was was a win and here
I mean it still looks overwhelming
really but it's it's not it's not clear
cut yeah Bishop takes this pattern ah
very nice line by the comp look at this
and now e5 takes d6y a very nice Queen
takes I take here and if take here the
sir I can't give this first and then 95
and white is winning this is very nice
so after taking he needs to go here and
then
this is excellent for white intending
here rook f6 and this is basically not
defensible yeah but this is not easy to
see I mean in a tournament game i would
i would just I would see that I guess
but here no and now I'm outplayed black
is excellent I have no tactics and she
controls the important squares so I hear
very easy could have him he played this
which is strategically fine but this was
oops just winning winning this this is
just just very bad Rock I've a digital
is much stronger check this keeps keeps
the edge but it's it's it's within
within within reason now I di think I'm
drawing it's a it's still a bit
problematic but this is this is really a
draw if he doesn't play g5 himself I
play g5 and it's just too close to you
never get anything on the queenside
alright thanks for watching